[Musique]
dommage
alors ces toiles nouveaux voisins way
pour info je m'appelle cinq moines à
élever le toit de cette fenêtre foxconn
salue on vient d'emménager
on est d'accord c'est un gros nounours
c'est pas contre toi ils supportent
personnes ouais elle vient d'en faire lé
prisonnier elle son père est un
psychopathe
tu crois qu'elle a une copine
[Musique]
l'abominable homme des neiges de
pasadena des manuscrits de chair de
poule pourquoi ils sont fermées à clé tu
as déverrouiller un livre nous alléger
le remettre à sa place ça y regarde
[Musique]
tiré du phénomène planétaire chair de
poule et l'abominable homme des neiges
est sorti d'un livre ça n'arrive jamais
à délibérer tous les monstres que
j'écris pour y aller les rires je suis
coincé continuer sans moi
savez-vous hockey mathias non plus bon
c'est pas cette année si on veut les
arrêter il faut les réexpédier dans les
livres vous avez lu si on connaît leurs
points faibles
ben est forte on peut tous les capturer
les seuls à pouvoir le faire
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai rien je n'ai toujours rire
affronter plus de monstres que dans vos
rêves les plus fous
dans une aventure incroyable faux
pouvais pas accélérer
c'est quelqu'un veut conduire à ma place
je passe au dessus
[Musique]
chair de poule et notre jardin peut-être
qu'ils sont gentils présenti carrément
pas gentil
[Applaudissements]